hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I'm your host Mike McCarty I'm
here with Rob handler hey and pleased to
have creative director will ho from Need
for Speed payback thanks for having me
yeah thanks for coming on I finally got
to show off more of Need for Speed
payback mm-hmm couple days ago at the ei
Prescott yeah it's been exciting yeah
get into the world yeah definitely saw
think at this point most people watching
will have seen like the gameplay
segments we saw right it was a very much
kind of gave a sense of the tone of the
game you're going for yeah the highway
heist right yeah we talked about that
like it seems very like action people
making like fast and furious rebels yeah
is that what you're going for something
you know it's been it's been really
great to reveal more of the game in
Hollywood because we're off we're
viewing Nitra speed through a Hollywood
lens we're taking everything that people
love from nature speed over the years
you know iconic cars and same
customization cop chases and tense races
you know gorgeous environments but then
sharply focusing all of that into a
playable action movie because I grew up
you know loving cars and loving you know
playing with cars and watching you know
car shows and car movies and everyone
has their favorite action scenes right
you know car chases you know bad guys
versus good guys you know insane stunts
and and just being able to present Need
for Speed in that way I think just
lights everyone's imaginations and gets
people excited right like with the
highway heist when people see you know
the car jumping out of this 18-wheeler
in motion on a highway people just care
oh my god deal it right yeah no I'm and
then also can we talk about the story
there's like three playable characters
and not mistaken right main characters
yeah there's three characters that you
drive as and you know that the reason
behind that is because you know coming
off of the last names people people
really want more variety right and more
reasons to race more motivation more
we're characters that they could relate
to and so we expanded the variety of
gameplay from the core Need for Speed
racing and drifting and style events and
added more action driving you know
missions that are you know like movies
where you have to take that package to
the destination on time or you have to
get that VIP from point A to point B
without getting caught and so we have
three characters than buddy that write
with Tyler who's the racer an inspiring
street racer we have Mac who's the show
winnings all about extreme driving and
stunts and drifting and then Jess is our
action movie hero he's the consummate
professional and who gets you know the
job done right and those three
characters represent the whole variety
of gameplay and they come together in
May
things like this one the highway heist
they have to collaborate they come have
to come together as a crew and they you
know in every action movie sequence
things go wrong right yeah I got the
best laid plans and things got
completely sideways and they have this
banter they have to improvise they have
to really cooperate in order to still
achieve their goals together it seems to
give a lot of unique ways to create like
dynamic missions more or less right like
you see the scene where I forget what
character it is but she jumps on to the
truck and then next you know it's the
over her ability to I guess heist it so
that's like a I guess interesting
interesting way of developing these
missions yeah the way we see it is that
you know it's still about you know that
core a need for speed gameplay right
it's about you know driving fast a car
through traffic right it's about you
know chasing down rivals and battling
and jostling with them and it's about
getting to a destination on time and
your reward for use of that destination
is these cool action movie moments right
give you a little breather you know give
you a little you know surprise it's a
delight you and then BOOM you know with
just coming out that's the fact I try to
the Koenigsegg that's a dynamic vehicle
switch a dynamic character switch so
you're playing as one character you're
playing as a different character and
seamlessly transitions from one to
another we've a number of missions in
the game from start to finish that
involve you experiencing those scenarios
from all three different points of view
cool so you didn't work in the 2015
reboot but you said you've worked on
past Need for Speed game you talked
about your experience or the series
leading up until now yeah so um you know
served my childhood dream to make you
know driving games and racing games you
know I'm just a car nut and so you know
it's a real privilege you know being a
fan of the early nature speeds like
nature's being three hot pursuit in
those games to finally work at Blackbaud
from Vancouver and it was privileged to
work in games like hopper c2 and the
PlayStation two underground series and
Most Wanted and that you know is sort of
a you know we like to think about the
golden era I mean nature speeds always
been great but you know really great
memories of that era and then you know
now I'm able to take that experience and
sort of come back to need for speed and
really think about well how do we take
all those core elements and make a
modern
right one that's you know thoroughly
contemporary one that is you know
speaking to players now right players
are more sophisticated now right we
serve advanced the breed and so people
are expecting you know a diverse open
world they're expecting lots to discover
a lot to collect more strategy more
choice more freedom right someone
someone comes in like like say I just
play a lot of shooters I play a lot of
strategy games and I know there are a
lot of racing games out there that
people play but if you wanted to
describe the Need for Speed formula the
kind of that structure of the game 3 how
would you describe it and how do those
tenets that you think of it can factor
in to payback yeah it's really about you
know it's about your favorite cars right
it's about choosing from a selection of
iconic cars and having that personal
relationship with the cars that you
choose and how you choose to customize a
visually right to make it a personal
expression of what you want and then to
upgrade it with the the parts that you
want right and that's a tune all those
parts into something that now you can
master in racing that you can master in
drifting that you know gets you through
the missions you know the way you want
right so that you can get maximum reward
and then so taking that avatar right the
car is the star all right and then
putting it in all these different
situations in the world I discovering
you know going through missions right
and playing through the single-player
campaign a game from start to finish it
is a bit of a revenge story this time I
won't spoil too much with it but it's a
play out that that's a revenge story in
with a stable of cars but then also in
the open world discovering more missions
discovering sides of us discovering
activities right now you could be going
around along this Highway and they're
billboards to smash right there big air
moments there are speed zones there
drift zones right so I think that you
know nature speed now is a proper
open-world game all right what's all
that discovery with all that freedom of
choice and non-linearity that players
expect yeah we saw in the footage like
briefly kind of
these the slow motion kind of crashes we
talk about the game mechanically like
what were some things you wanted to do
that maybe the reboot didn't really
accomplish or what you learned from the
reboot that you wanted to make it feel
the way you get once came to feel when
you're having I think something that we
really keyed on early on is that sense
of you really feeling the tension of
chasing down AI rivals and so as you're
going to erase as you're going through a
mission in this case we've got these
house enforcer cars the black ones right
here you're barreling down on them and
you're really trying to remove them
because they're protecting the the calm
of the cargo on the truck we really want
to dial in our a I with a bit of an
attitude problem and so that you know as
he approached me you feel that tension
you're going to overtake them and I shot
them and they're gonna fight back
they're come they're gonna make your
life difficult for you right
so we're battling with these house
enforcers and one and that's a reward
right yeah because you've made that
happen yeah that action movie moment
happened yourself and you get to be the
star of that then you move on to the
next action movie moment yeah right
start giving way to the climax I'm sure
there are plenty of things you can rim
these guys like a barn or yeah I think
horse players players are going to
discover you know through open-world
exploration what they choose to leverage
you know in these blockbuster missions
right you can use traffic cars to your
advantage you can weave guardrails you
can use any of the objects on the
roadside and to help eliminate these
rivals yeah how does a fortune Valley
like that factor in I guess like two
questions like why choose to set in what
I assume is kind of a proxy for Las
Vegas it's definitely a southwestern us
yeah right yeah it's not just one city
or another that's a definitely you know
coming back to the theme of variety in
what fans have asked for over the last
two years is we really don't want to
pick a location where you know every
region of this map is is different right
visually different and also has gameplay
that's matched to that visual variety so
we have a core city that you know has
casinos it has an entertainment district
but in addition to that glamour side
we've got you know gritty side all right
we've got desert we've got industrial
areas we've got construction sites we've
got a spill away from certain action
movies that you know it's cool to dive
into right and then when you get out of
the city you go into the canyons right
extreme deep canyons right now we've got
this mantra where if you can see it you
can drive to it so maybe at the top of
the canyons I look down at the bottom
okay how do I get to that River way down
there or you're down through ever how do
I get to that bridge let's way up in
this guy all right then we've got
awesome mountains right for those
switchbacks right now doing you're
drifting up and down switchbacks right
and extreme elevation change and then
what's anchoring it is this area that
you see is the desert right this vast
desert in the middle of the map that you
can you know really book it off of the
tarmac and explore this vast desert yeah
one thing I liked about a Forza horizon
3 recently was that I could just I
didn't have to like necessarily focus on
doing like this challenge or this
challenge or finding this car I could
just kind of drive in this open world is
there an effort to kind of appeal to
players who would just like to explore
like Fortune Valley and absolutely yeah
there's going to be tons of activities
for you discover you discover some some
side races you're going to discover
roaming racers it's you know because
we've got this enormous street racing
culture in Fortune Valley so you're
going to be you know discovering guys
who are going to challenge you right and
then you have rivalries and ladders
between these guys right yeah meet
several different Street leagues and
while you're exploring fortunate Valley
and then all of this has leaderboards
right so as you're exploring you know
you know posting times posting scores
you're going to be compared against your
friends and we're going to push the most
relevant scores to use so that it's
really easy for you to one-up your
friends yeah I think it's the first
thing we noticed when we saw payback was
that presumably there are no more
live-action cutscenes the 2015 reboot as
someone who didn't work on that reboot
and you came into as a creative director
on payback but you like you said you'd
had lengthy experience in the series was
there anything that the team learned
from the reboot that they wanted to
avoid or implement further in payback I
think definitely with the the cutscenes
we really want them to be more relatable
but also a lot more flexibility in where
they could be set because we have this
gorgeous open world with tons of
beautiful locations and we've got 24
hour time of day in this world so it's
nice to be able to set our cutscenes you
know with our characters next to their
cars you know interacting with their
cars anywhere in the world right and
that just adds to the level of immersion
in the world right you're never taken
out of the world to watch a movie and
then come back into the world you're
always in
the story you're always in this fiction
in fortune belly I do have to ask we
mentioned like fast and furious what
other kind of like car movies heist
movies race movies are influencing you
as someone who's super into Hollywood
yeah it's probably too many to lift
right like if you could name like you
know any movie that you've watched right
it could be like a cult movie it could
be an action movie it could be like a
you know even like a sci-fi movie with
like insane chases involving tons of
vehicles you know great stunts great
drifting you know heroic moments just
like you know just stick in your mind
you know we kind of have a team that
lives and breathes that and has grown up
in that kind of culture right and we're
able to you know it's really fun in our
jam sessions with our team to just go
like what were we gonna do for this one
how are we going to one-up the last
mission that we did right and we're just
picking and choosing from like literally
decades of experience of watching these
movies yeah it's pretty easy pouring you
know those memories into Need for Speed
payback yeah I was watching bullet last
night there's no animosity and like that
could be a great nuts and a knack
opportunity I don't know how much you
can talk on it but like you mentioned
like Hot Pursuit earlier mm-hmm as far
as like cop chases or anything like that
I mean there will be moments of that
obviously mm-hmm
I think I heard somewhere about like the
ability to again utilize your
environment mm-hmm you know cheat your
way yeah you know get them to force them
on like a turn-off or stuff like that
you speak and anything yeah so something
about the cops is that's you know going
back to the story for a man is you know
we've got this sort of evil cartel
called the house and while they're evil
is because they control everything and
control the casinos and control the
cartels that control the cops even so
you know when our crew they're sort of
you know kicking up a fuss in the sea of
silver rock the house you know they're
not taking it lightly so they're sending
the cops at you with full force yeah so
we don't have these cops are just
cruising around like security guards or
mall cops anymore every time you see the
cops you are going to feel anxious about
it they're going to go oh my god what am
i I do about this so we we amp up the
level of the cop cases right away and
we're bringing back you know spike
strips we're bringing our roadblocks
we've got Akio copters tracking you and
we're bringing back rhinos right yeah
because people go oh my god there's
something barreling down at me trying to
kill me yeah so we've got all those
elements and
cops and cop cases are going to be
pretty intense cool awesome uh so last
question when can we play need for speed
payback yes the need for speed payback
is coming in November 10th on placing
for on Xbox one and Windows PC cool will
ho thank you so much for joining us
thank you so much yeah have a got
arrested an awesome thanks yeah if
anybody watching we will have many more
demos and interviews like this
throughout the week up on our GameSpot
III stage we'll have a lot of people
going on in our co-op stage downstairs
but for all that for news for more
interviews you can stay tuned here
throughout the week